[Music]
oh
crazy
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys guys come on get out of the way
[Music]
[Music]
oh
many
um
oh
down here
meet him
[Music]
is
okay
hey
we need some space to work all right we
respect what you guys got to do but we
also need some space as well okay so
please step back right back right back
to the front of my vehicle please right
back keep going you're doing very well
thank you very much folks right back all
right really appreciate it thank you
just some space all right
he's right back thanks a lot all right
no
[Music]
thank you thank you i appreciate that
god is with you
god is with you
god is with us
just right on the center media in there
sir
let's watch your step you're getting
pretty close
thank you very much
thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
i can't
you guys are still
shooting happen to catch something going
on excuse me
pretty nice
yeah exactly there you go cbc right here
that's why it's happening
right there guys
like this
all right
[Music]
they're terrible thank you absolutely
your grandchildren
marshmallows in ukraine yet your fake
news and fake wars yeah all right that's
funny
that's funny you're playing the same
script all over again it's not the first
time we hear about [ __ ] kovid you
know that
like 20 years we've been hearing about
it
yeah how long have you been trying to
push that vaccine
yeah really
actually if you just look at the stats
from
the ontario
[Music]
who are you guys with
he had five
the love is over there there's the real
show up there
let's go tucker carlson
um
so we'll do that
[Music]
and where's everyone else
okay
[Music]
like it's so slippery
[Music]
uh
let's just move back for a second i want
to make sure
[Music]
crisis
yeah
where are we going over now with
important news
the hugging the loving
tell the truth prostitute yeah
hey you proud of yourself
hey that was a good that was well staged
jay
crisis actor getting our ass arrested
and you guys just happened to be there
i can do this all day
yeah watch where you're going
should look forward to
tell the truth they don't know what the
truth is
they they get so much money from our
government
thank you
uh
a
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
great
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like stands for falling out in a drought
no flow rain wasn't pouring down you see
that thing was all around see my motors
kind of lounge didn't know which which
way to turn slow was cool but i still
felt burned energy up you can feel my
surge imma kill everything like this
purge
blame everything that i say man i'll see
you deflate let me elevate this in a
prank
my
[Music]
here go back yep
we'll get a plan together so that way
like
you know we can't stay out for like four
more hours
dress appropriate wow
[Music]
are you on with them
[Music]
homeless person
oh
[Music]
thanks for having my six our beer
that was you know the hardest
interesting crap
didn't i put on my light jacket
that should make it fun
well we made the sixth
i felt my brain slowly melting
the hunger
there's too much freedom for me
c
yeah turn that
wow
hey we got an arrest on tv that's sweet
even though they arrested literally the
wrong person
you